you posted your year wrap up streams i
think it was it was a ton bro but i feel
like that there's like a narrative that
you that you would kind of acknowledge
that you would like like people say that
you have fallen off yeah yeah
um how do you when you hear that how do
you feel about it
um
i just feel like
i don't think i fell off i think i may
be more stagnated like maybe i'm
where i stopped at
and you know to people that might
be there
they might think that's falling off
but uh as you can see the streams are
not you know nothing has changed i mean
[ __ ] moonwalking in calabasas is a
platinum yeah yeah no i'm saying and
that song really took off once you got
on i'm still selling platinum records i
know i don't think people understand
like you're still getting plaques the
streams and all that they don't they
don't get to see that you feel me like
yeah you don't know they also don't want
to pay attention to that because yeah
yeah like you don't know how much this
song streamed for real like just did 200
million streams
over and over and over again did you
feel like um there was like a gift in
the curse coming out swinging with like
a number one record like fatian well
that's where i think the falloff thing
comes in it's like people want to see me
on the hot 100. cause tatiana was such a
[ __ ] massive
moment yeah it was like it's hard for
anyone to have two of those and i'm not
saying that you won't have another one
but no for sure yeah but yeah it's not
gonna happen
back to back like you know it's gonna
like i got it yeah i gotta find my
smooth because that wasn't really my
my angle when i when i came in i had way
more like cripped out songs yes you did
doctoriana kind of like pushed me into
the land of oh you got to make this type
of music
mm-hmm
but i got [ __ ] like bleeded and all
that type of stuff and then i think
daddy went platinum right
bro i got i got somebody platinum i'm
already known
even like
i probably got like 10 blacks that's
crazy but
they will never know that because
well they will know one day i'll flex